alors je suis très fier très heureuse
c'est un grand honneur d'être ce soir
devant vous et je vais tâcher d'être à
la hauteur
enfin la hauteur pas trop quand même
parce que voyez vous moi grandir devenir
une grande
j'arrive pas enfin c'est pas mon truc
alors il ya trois ans j'ai rencontré les
personnes qui comme moi étaient
chatouiller à l'idée de ne pas grandir
complètement qui avait encore envie de
croire à des mythes à des comptes à des
légendes de leur enfance mais plus que
ça allait vivre en vrai et à les faire
vivre aux autres aurélien la faune à
mahé vie et guillaume trautmann ensemble
nous avons fondé holt chez walt nous ne
pensons pas que les dinosaures ont
disparu de la surface de notre planète
nous les cherchons dans les eaux
boueuses du fleuve congo chez walt nous
ne pensons pas que les trésors s'observe
derrière les vitrines des musées où sont
enfermés dans les coffres forts
nous les trouverons dans les poubelles
chez walt nous travaillons main dans la
main avec les sirènes les licornes les
éléphants qui vole les têtes de mule les
brebis égarées
chez bolt nous croyons au merveilleux au
pouvoir magnétique des lieux obèse
endormie mais laissez moi plutôt vous
conter l'histoire de walt
donc wait c'est avant tout un groupe
immobilier qui crée élabore et anime des
projets des lieux surprenants qui font
voyager les visiteurs dans le temps et
dans l'espace
comment en les plongeant dans une
scénographie une mise en scène qui est
animée et exploiter chaque jour alors vu
comme ça sous forme de petites patates
ils ont pas l'air très surprenant mais
j'y reviendrai ces lieux donc sont
ouverts tous les jours au public
il génère donc les revenus issus de
l'activité des bars de la restauration
de la location nos espaces ou des
marchandises que l'on vend dans nos
boutiques ses revenus nous les
réinvestissons dans des projets qui nous
tiennent à coeur et qui ont un impact
sur la société
alors là c'est pareil j'ai mis que trois
patates mais dans les faits on a plutôt
une dizaine
deux projets qui couvrent des
thématiques aussi diverses que le café
de spécialité le commerce équitable la
poterie artisanale ou leur traitement
des déchets dans les premiers mois
d'existence de ces projets walt joue le
rôle de mère nourricière
elle apporte les finances nécessaires à
la mise en place finances qui viennent
des revenus des lieux je le rappelle
elle prodigue ses conseils en
organisation et en management
elle accompagne les porteurs de projets
dans leur quotidien
les projets trouvent également leur
place dans nos lieux ces lieux
deviennent alors leurs premiers clients
et des plateformes commerciales pour
tester leur stratégie et puisque walt
est actionnaire majoritaire des lieux et
des projets et bien finalement tout le
monde a intérêt à ce que les lieux se
porte bien et soit régulièrement visités
à ce que les projets se développent
devienne autonome et rentable et à ce
que finalement le groupe s'enrichissent
et ce qui se passe au final hop c'est
que quand tout marche bien et bien les
emplois que nous créons sont pérennisés
sur le long terme l'impact qu'on a sur
la société grâce à ses projets et bien
grandit au fur et à mesure que les
projets se multiplient et finalement le
groupe s'enrichit et grandit chaque jour
encore et encore parce que la morale de
cette histoire c'est que de cette
poignée d'entrepreneurs qui ne voulait
pas grandir est né un écosystème qui lui
grandit chaque jour fait grandir les
autres est un peu le monde aussi alors
ça c'est pour la démonstration théorique
passons maintenant aux contes de fées je
vais vous raconter trois histoires qui
vont vous montrer comment walt fait
grandir les gens les choses et les
projets dans la réalité
alors je vais commencer par le comptoir
général que vous connaissez peut-être le
compte en général c'est un lieu que vous
ont fait grandir depuis plusieurs années
et comme tous les lieux de gaulle ton
vous et raconte une histoire
alors l'histoire du comptoir général on
a été la chercher
il ya une centaine d'années dans ce qui
était le lieu au tout départ le comptoir
général il ya 100 ans en cdd
curry des écuries qui hébergeait les
chevaux qui tractait les péniches
marchande le long du canal saint martin
et comme on voulait un lieu ouvert aux
cultures du monde
on s'est dit pas ce qu'on va faire du
comptoir c'est un énorme relais
commercial un comptoir général justement
placé au croisement des routes de l'inde
de l'afrique de l'asie de l'europe et
qui va vous montrer comme faisait ses
marchands qui s'arrêtait dansez dansez
caravansérail du moyen-orient qu'on peut
festoyer échanger apprendre beaucoup sur
les cultures et aussi négocier ses
marchandises
on a donc recréer un certain nombre de
petites scènes de petites échoppes dans
lesquels vous pouvez acheter des
marchandises et l'histoire que l'on vous
raconte c'est aussi dans ce que vous
voyez dans ce que vous buvez dans vos
verres dans votre assiette
puisque nous proposons une cuisine du
monde qui change toutes les semaines
dans les marchandises comme je vous le
disais que vous pouvez acheter
et puis également dans notre
programmation événementielle puisque
chaque jour vous avez des événements
musicaux
vous avez des projections vous avez des
événements participatifs également qui
vous montre à chaque fois une facette
d'une culture du monde différente
alors aujourd'hui le comptoir général
c'est 4 millions de chiffre d'affaires
ces deux cent cinquante mille visiteurs
par an dont plus de la moitié viennent
de pays étrangers
c'est aussi une clientèle fidèle puisque
70% d'entre eux viennent plus de trois
fois par mois dans notre lieu le
comptoir général aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment le poumon de l'écosystème bolt
qui permet et je vous renvoie mon petit
schéma tout à l'heure de faire vivre des
projets alors les projets le premier
projet dont je vais vous parler qui
s'appelle à la recherche du mot qu'elle
aime mb c'est l'histoire de michel donc
il était une fois michel michel ballot
la première fois qu'on a rencontré
michel
il nous a dit je vais faire une
découverte une découverte énorme
je vais découvrir un dinosaure le
dernier dinosaure vivent pas denver le
dernier dinosaure le mokélé mbembé alors
le mokélé mbembé qu'est ce que c'est et
bien c'est un animal qui aurait la forme
d'un peu
diplodocus alors que ce soit un
dinosaure un reptile à mammifères on ne
le sait pas car personne ne l'a jamais
vu mise à part les pygmées ce qu'on sait
c'est qui vit dans la forêt du bassin du
congo
donc la forêt du bassin du congo c'est
une énorme forêt primitive en plein
coeur de l'afrique qui fait plusieurs
milliers de kilomètres carrés et dans
lequel mise à part les pygmées et michel
peu d'hommes ont mis les pieds michel ça
fait 15 ans qu'ils cherchent le mot clé
est aujourd'hui il a réuni un certain
nombre d' indices qui lui permettent
d'affirmer que la découverte est
imminente
ces indices quels sont ils et bien par
exemple des empreintes qui l'a
photographié alors on le voit peut-être
pas sur la photo mais les empreintes
elles font plus de 30 cm de diamètre et
elles n'appartiennent à aucune espèce
connue
il est également des témoignages des
communautés locales des pygmées qui
vivent dans la forêt et qui affirme
avoir vu récemment la bête vivante
sortir le coût de l'eau il est également
d énorme cavité des énormes caverne qui
sont creusées à même les berges et qui
sont des niches vraisemblablement mais
qui ne peuvent pas et ça des
scientifiques en ont témoigné être le
fruit du travail d'un élément d'un
éléphant pardon ou d'un crocodile alors
quand michel nous a parlé de son
aventure
on a fait waouh le soleil tape fort au
cameroun mais michel on a envie de t d
on a envie de t&d parce que on pense que
faire encore des découvertes de cet
acabit aujourd'hui c'est génial surtout
quand c'est fait par un explorateur
amateurs et passionnés
alors qu'est ce qu'on a fait pour aider
michel et bien on a fait plein de choses
on a lancé une campagne de crowdfunding
on a cherché des sponsors
on a cherché des mécènes on a fait appel
à la générosité du public et on a envoyé
michel sur place deux fois mais deux
fois c'est pas assez
michel ses huit fois ses 20 x 30 x qu'il
a besoin d'être sur place
pourquoi
parce qu'au cameroun il pose tous les
jours des caméras qui captent qui
capture les mouvements il faut le
relever régulièrement pour s'assurer que
le dinosaure n'est pas passé parce que
quand un pygmée vous dit j'ai vu le coût
de la bête sortir du fleuve
eva voiture place et il faut aller voir
tout de suite ce que le mot kelly va pas
attendre six mois que vous reveniez et
puis peut-être que la façon la plus
facile d'apercevoir la bête c'est
prendre une chaise c'est s'asseoir
devant c'est énorme cavité et d'attendre
qu'ils passent à tête comment faire donc
on a discuté longtemps avec michel et
puis on s'est dit en fait michel à
chaque fois qu'on parle avec toi c'est
génial quand on lis tes aventures des
expéditions tu es rencontres avec les
pygmées tes aventures de juin quand tu
croises des goryl et des éléphants sur
la piste du mot clé
eh ben on a super envie de venir avec
toi et si nous on pense comme ça on se
dit que d'autres aussi peuvent le penser
alors ce qu'on a fait ce qu'on a créé un
projet entrepreneurial une société qui
s'appelle avant tours et qui met en
contact des gens comme vous et moi pour
aller avec michel sur place chercher le
mot clé est ce que font ces nez aux
aventuriers quand il accompagne michel
et de trois ordres
la première il permet à michel ballot
d'être régulièrement sur place et donc
d'avoir plus de chance de découvrir la
bête
ensuite en tant que ressortissants
étrangers il oblige les autorités
locales à mieux protéger les zones que
vous allez visiter et ainsi à lutter
contre le braconnage et puis ce qui se
passe aussi c'est qu'en créant une micro
tourisme et bien vous en fait bénéficier
les populations locales
les pygmées et puis qui sait peut-être
qu'un jour le jour michel découvrira le
mokélé vous serez peut-être avec lui
alors
après les dinosaures d'afrique je vous
ramener dans un endroit tout aussi
glamour les poubelles parisienne il
était une fois martine martin est une
bille fine alors une bille fink est ce
que c'est une personne qui fouillent le
contenu des poubelles qui en récupère
certains objets et qui tente par la
suite de le revendre il y à quelques
siècles on appelait ça des chiffonniers
des biffins aujourd'hui il y en a
environ 5000 dans la région parisienne
et on constate ce même phénomène dans
toutes les grandes villes de france
alors il faut savoir que c'est quand
même une activité extrêmement précaires
vous rendez compte essayer de revendre
des objets perdus des déchets et puis ça
se fait souvent de manière illégale
donc c'est une situation assez difficile
et qui ne paraît pas de survivre alors
quand martin est venu nous expliquer son
histoire quand elle nous a dit qu'elle
faisait ça depuis plus de 40 ans on
s'est dit mais c'est pas juste sortir
ces personnes de la précarité qu'il faut
faire c'est remettre au goût du jour un
véritable métier celui de beef
alors on a créé un projet
entrepreneurial une société qui
s'appelle le centre des objets perdus ou
globalement on fait exactement ce que
faisait les biffins auparavant mais de
manière structurée et légal on a
commencé par les employés par leur
donner des moyens par achille et camions
de l'ébène par signer des contrats avec
des entreprises des particuliers pour
aller récupérer plein de choses des tas
de choses dont les gens ne veulent plus
à l'occasion d'un déménagement de vide
greniers quand il faut débarrasser des
hangars avant de les détruire et on
récupère tout et c'est ça qui fait notre
différence
on vient pas juste trier les objets qui
pourraient avoir de la valeur
on prend tous les objets perdus et une
fois arrivé au centre qui se trouve à
montreuil
eh bien on les trie selon deux filières
la première filière c'est celle des
objets décoratifs
parce que ces objets peuvent encore
servir parce qu'ils ont du cachet et
bien nous les revendons de manière
légale et moderne sur des plateformes de
distribution digitale ou dans des
corners physique il en existe d'ailleurs
un au comptoir général
là est tout le reste ce qui est cassé ce
qui est sous format de matière eh bien
on le tri selon la nature cartons
papiers plastiques métaux et on le
revend à des professionnels du recyclage
industriel qui nous payent pour ce
service
au final ce qui se passe c'est que non
seulement on est quelques biffins à
sortir de la précarité m'ont également
un impact sur l'environnement
parce que tous ces objets qu'on récupère
aussi bien dans la rue que chez les
particuliers
eh bien il aurait de grandes chances de
finir à l'incinération et vous savez
quand on incinère des déchets ça génère
une certaine pollution aujourd'hui avec
ce centre à montreuil on est d'à peu
près une dizaine de biffins et on
recycle 40 tonnes de déchets par mois
imaginez ce qui va se passer le jour on
a deux sens entre comme ça vous ne
regarderez plus votre poubelle du même
oeil
c'est sûr alors il ya un aspect des
comptes que j'ai pas encore évoqué ce
sont les personnages les rois les
princesses les magiciens les farfadets
les dragons ses personnages ce sont eux
les membres de notre équipe
ceux qui travaillent dans nos lieux ceux
qui sont nos porteurs de projets ce sont
eux qui vous racontent les histoires que
nous inventons et ces gens là aussi on
essaie de les faire grandir
par exemple il y en a certains qui ont
été embauchés comme barman et qui
aujourd'hui son directeur de nos
établissements sont devenus nos conseils
juridiques
il y en a qui hier vous vous servez
votre café et qui aujourd'hui exploitent
leur propre filière de cafés de
spécialité en direct d'afrique
ces jours là je pourrais passer la
soirée à vous raconter leur histoire
parce que c'est eux qui donnent le goût
et la saveur de tout ce que nous
racontons mais je dois conclure je dois
conclure cette histoire d'entrepreneurs
qui souffrait du syndrome de peter pan
qui n'avait pas envie de grandir et qui
pour compenser on crée un projet qui
fait grandir chaque jour et qui fait
grandir les autres et pour cela
j'emploierai une expression consacrée et
de circonstance
eh bien ma slide à sauter mais ça disait
to be continued
je vous remercie beaucoup